nous sommes à l'avant-garde de l'un des
plus grands progrès de l'humanité
[Musique]
il ne ressemble à rien de ce qu'on a pu
voir jusqu'ici
et il est totalement sous notre contrôle
on lance la séquence
qu'est ce qui m'est arrivé vous avez été
tués
vous a offert une deuxième chance j'ai
mis au point une armée de soldats comme
vous plus performants améliorée
bienvenue au cirque
technologie qui coule dans vos veines
vous rendra plus rapide plus forts
évoqués rire instantanément
je sens qu'un truc qui va pas ils
tombent manipuler entrer la prochaine
cible à éliminer
vous êtes mon arme vous m'avez fabriqués
maison contrôleraient pas indéfiniment
ils vont craquer
je me réjouis la france
tu peux pas rentrer aucun risque
nous emmerde